today on our show some Marvel trailers
that we're fit to print
that's right Comic Con just happened and
Marvel just unfurled all over us in Hall
H leotis everything looking at all
we see the bush we see in dick we've
seen at all we're gonna talk about it
man right here on today's Batman I'll
bet more shooting webs
welcome to fat man I'll bet and I'm
Kevin Smith I'm workman Arden for are we
go any further folks to tell you what
Marvel did to us over this weekend it
was a good thing we got sponsor audible
audible you hear that that's the good
folks at audible.com telling you to come
in read a book
can you not read audible.com they'll
teach you to read that's not what their
service don't read to you helps if you
know how to read a book in advance but
they do have books that they read to you
it's like the lap of the Internet you
could sit on and have somebody read you
a book not amazing is that what you
always wanted man audible audible if you
want to listen to it audible has it
that's served that's their catchphrase
give me a single with more than 250,000
with more than 250,000 audiobooks and
spoken word audio products you'll find
what you're looking for at audible.com
get a free 30 day trial today by signing
up at www.cannainsider.com/itunes
oh I got through an extra [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] me reading the book
that's not even in the rule book shut
the [ __ ] up yes right dude that's how I
roll I'm like I don't count reward
people for supporting me I reward the
people who had hidden supportable has
everything I mean come on dude do like
few driving anywhere and stuff like that
get some damn audible so you could stick
it in your have somebody tell you if
you're on a train commuting back and
forth from work and your diet of
listening to music mmm get a book in
your head if you still want to talk to
your wife anymore get a book in your
head I'm sorry Warren peace Wow
children who needs children book in your
sea in four months just a book in it
trying to be book smart audible.com
ladies and gentlemen II get it free apps
for iPhones iPad Android and Windows
Phone download and listen on an iOS
device Android Kindle Fire windows
and over 500 mp3 players man
all over the [ __ ] planet unlike
streaming a rental service with audible
you own your books yeah cuz who wants to
give that [ __ ] back there's a book in
your head keep it on your head unless
you read the book and you don't like it
then Greg I don't want this book came
back like somebody exotic said they get
people on audible.com going I would like
to return fifty Shades of Grey
we can't do that like well it wasn't
dirty enough for me I mean it's very
dirty and it was kind of chased but your
book is soiled sir we're not gonna take
your soiled book these digital pages are
stuck together sir you can't take it
back audible will take it back they
don't care if you come to the book my
library assess your books anytime
anywhere right from your smartphones
audible.com man give them give give them
your Patriot it's just [ __ ] they they
sponsored this show that that'll tell
you all you need to know give the gift
of books in your head I like that
somebody higher audible give the books
of give them gifts and books in your
head enough with the ads man thank you
audible for sponsoring this show and
this show is all about the Marvel
trailers that we saw on Marvel lusts as
per usual Marvel could be counted on to
pull out all the stops and [ __ ] drown
you in goodness they live for San Diego
I mean they look to make these movies
and make money but I think Kevin Vai
he's got a secret he conducted his own
panel if I if I City there's a mic was
there a
Hardwick was there all right but [ __ ]
he's like all over a man he's like kid
in a candy store he loves yeah he's just
the puppet master that's right man he's
like [ __ ] that old dude in the movies
making little dolls and sending them out
to kill fun I like this guy's spirit man
he makes cool [ __ ] movies not even me
trying to get a job I just [ __ ] like
what a dude does seriously um what did
they show in hallways well there are a
couple presentations that a Netflix
presentation yes so let's talk about
that first man because let's be honest
like we're all waiting for Luke Cage
holy [ __ ] Luke Cage about to happen
folks we have daredevil we're Jessica
Jones
now we're gonna have Luke Cage after
that iron fist which is shooting right
now and they also showed a [ __ ]
cheeser for
in Hall H and then after that they're
gonna give us the defenders which they
also showed us a teaser for granted was
just a title treatment and new dialogue
sound like a stick stick but still do
the fact that it's on the horizon enough
topic entitled treatment what do you
think tell me about Luke Cage first Luke
Cage I am in the bag for anything that
starts with [ __ ] ODB yeah shimmy
shimmy shimmy yo shimmy ya ya [ __ ]
bulletproof the Hodari coke is the
showrunner gave a big panel as one does
and he he kind of steered straight into
the fact that it's about time we see a
bulletproof black man yeah in a gray
hoodie walking into a building and
getting shot that's pretty lucky not for
[ __ ] around that's pretty impressive
yeah especially when you consider the
political overtones of a dude in a
hoodie
yes yes that is that is black lives
matter and all up in your grill that
dude does not wear a headband just once
I'm just saying Swede Christmas put it
on and then take it off even in a store
like he's going for the store sweet
Christmas unless there's like the
Halloween episode of Luke Cage where
he's got to dress up to hit a
discotheque
you're wrong I'll predict it rather yet
given defenders he wears it oh you think
so all [ __ ] yes by the time they put him
in Danny ran together and they're heroes
friar and defenders at least one scene
he's got the metal here's the question
doesn't Danny ran where the head piece
they didn't show it in the trailer but
I've heard yes he does the only reason I
would put him in the head piece is it
because it's [ __ ] amazing my spot if
the head piece actually makes him
vulnerable like if he puts it on it and
dampens the gift so that he can feel so
he can be cut so that he can wound and
be a human being again
he wears a head piece that's just that's
all I'm saying a good [ __ ] pole um
all right what else about the Luke Cage
trailer we got to see do you think
what's-her-face
who actress I love alfre woodard mm she
she not playing the same character from
civil wars she I don't think so not at
all right
so she gets to play two characters in
the Marvel Universe yeah Matt last Matt
our producer Matt come up here and tell
us about Matt saw will switch from the
Netflix trailers which look fantastic
get in here and they announce the
daredevil getting a season alright
alright this Matt Lee Jim you all know
everybody I'm not Matt was in Hall H for
the spider-man presentation yes what was
Todd so they start off with the the high
school yearbooks of all the other
Avengers and it was actually like the
actors in high school which was a lot of
fun it was to Joan Jets bad reputation
and then they cut to footage of like his
science like his schedule his school
schedule okay so you see him in like
science class you see him but they they
also kind of play with it they had like
a women study class at 10:00 but it was
actually him and his best friend Ned
Leeds played by Jacob battle on I want
to say yeah yeah and they're like
checking out the girls as they walk by
than they do web design but it's
actually his chemistry class where he's
like making like sticky web fluid like
but it's like off to the side like he
pulls the desk grow up and it was trying
to hide it from his teacher but then at
the very very end he has study hall and
he like looks at his watch and he's like
oh I got it
I gotta go I think it's the Tony Stark
watch yeah I think so and he goes oh I
gotta go and then the girl across from
hymns and die is played by me playing I
think Michelle Gonzalez says where are
you always leaving to Peter and that's
where you get like that classic sort of
Peter Parker and high school sort of
thing of like which gotta hide my
superhero illness and classic goes back
to the comics because they've really got
to do it in the movie yeah like he was a
high schooler for a minute in the first
movie and then out and you know he
graduated high school in the second
round of movies but they should really
spend as much time in high school as
possible because that's who's I mean
look Peter Parker and spider-man will
always be interesting but Peter Parker
the boy more so than Peter Parker the
man has always
been interesting and a way for kid into
that universe Iron Man Superman Batman
Peter Parker just a boy so it's like
adulthood where that juiceless Ananda
and you only get to do that with him for
like very very little cuz before you
know it Tom Hollands gonna be in the
panel they mentioned that he's in his
sophomore year in high school high
school the rumor is that will get it's
like Harry Potter where we get like a
different year so next the next movie
will be him as a junior than the next
movie but um as a senior oh my god I
want this so badly yeah that's what
Buffy did I mean Buffy stood where there
is a sophomore and then by the third
season she graduates from high school
yeah like you can still do that if you
make these once a year so homecoming
third one could be graduation day and
what it's the middle one prom uh yeah
but you just had homecoming what's the
diff
well cuz proms when you get all dressed
up home except for homecoming game yeah
it's like it's a rally more than have
like a homecoming dance maybe but if
they show him in the spider suit very
briefly very very briefly there were
shots a couple weeks ago like behind the
scenes they had their shots of him on
like the concrete standard like truck
you know so they had that very briefly
so that's what they did when they show
when he said I've got to go they showed
him in the spider suit like some
previous stuff one of the things that I
thought was interesting they showed
Boheme Woodbine like robbing a place and
it looked like he had two other guys I
think they're doing enforcers so Montana
fancy Dan and ox Wow I think I think I
don't know like it was like a house
doing his first villain ever because
they show jury all true and then I was
at a very end of footage what was the
footage I mean his outfit wasn't
implying on wings what was it like no it
was it was him on wings like it was like
kind of like a shot looking straight up
like the wings like drone
they're like drone wings yeah and it's
like he kind of like zooms down and
hovers right above the ground and that
was the end of the footage more or less
yeah oh that's a concept
that's not what they showed in the panel
but yeah all right so dr. strange Ino is
my guy yes if I didn't have the Doctor
Strange trailer coming Thor would be the
one I was looking forward to the most
why so they they showed behind the
scenes stuff very quickly up at the top
you see Chris Hemsworth with long hair
then you see him with short hair with
war paint on then it cuts two quick
shots of like spaceships and all this
other random stuff that you wouldn't
expect to see in a Thor movie but with
it being a road trip you then see Planet
Hulk Planet Hulk elements and it's like
legit full-on planet whole you see the
three vis of Hulk and Thor running each
other budget and a gladiator pit and
here both of them like rolling screaming
at each other and then at the very end
they show a Hulk in slow motion raising
his fist back flying towards searcher
and this fire demon takes up the whole
damn screen like it's he's a massive
actual fire demon light and creepy as
[ __ ] dude it's dude it's like a longer
wingspan than one I've got that
headpiece that they've got and then
finners wolf was also in it like a giant
like 20-foot wolf just like walking on
the bike hillside
it's like bonkers what they showed is
bonkers and what did they talk about
black panther Lupita Nyong'o black
panther was just like the cast they
didn't really have anything to show no I
mean they haven't even started filming
it they don't really like earlier era
from Walking Dead as the leader of the
Michelle Michelle Michelle and Michael B
Jordan is playing kill mark geomungo
yeah so he's a villain yeah
he's the villain in the film he's one of
two villains from what I mean because
Lapita also Wow yeah from pre Bobby man
yeah
hippy cream okay and then they now it's
cat marble of course brie Larson playing
Captain Marvel which a lot of us do is I
thought that was official like it's for
real it's forever but they're nowhere
near shooting that movie yeah they're
out of a director it's like they see
yeah that's right they didn't announce a
director
what is it 20 like 19 or so just yeah
they start filming next year though
alright and then what else did we see I
saw you sub guardians I did let's talk
to dr. strange doctor strength you're
good thank you sir format everybody dr.
strange trailer good really good but
like not that different from the last
dr. strange no no I mean it's definitely
leaning heavily unlike magic inception
yeah in a way that if you don't like
Inception there's a lot of inception
yeah there's a bunch of there's a ton of
inception I kind of wanted more of what
the rest of the movie was like I get it
cities are bending but give me more more
more MORE but Shambhala is the Wi-Fi
password it was it was pretty sweet
pretty as an excellent button into that
trailer it's like we're not savages
and then of course the there is the best
trailer you know the one that everyone
was Paul I don't even know if say it was
the best but it was fun I was there for
it guardians of the galaxy vol 2 we ran
a trailer and it was like being in Rome
for a mass done by the Pope there was
that much religious fervor in the room
you could not have sustained staying in
that room and being a nerd to that
trailer the spirit swept you up even if
you were the world's most hardcore hater
of guardians of the galaxy and who the
[ __ ] would that be except they be Hitler
this thing played
unbelievably [ __ ] well now I was I
was honestly I was so glad I was in the
room for
because it was a singular comic-con
experience where it's like this is what
it's all about yeah
six thousand [ __ ] people lent all
their energy to the screen to watch Kurt
Russell become ego the [ __ ]
spellbinding I can't believe they let us
know that look at the mustache - they
literally told us like that was
something they could have held out very
honest they could held that until we
were in the theaters man like who
star-lords dad they flat out told us in
the room and stuff baby Groot there's
you're too [ __ ] old get ready - yeah
oh my god get ready to make it rain for
your children with all manner of baby
Groot gear because wow that looked too
[ __ ] cool all of it look cool man
James Gunn just [ __ ] beautiful in a
big bad way like that's the one we all
dream about I don't know when it's dude
they don't know if they gave a date or
anything like next year I think cannot
[ __ ] wait man
the you know the rocket the rocket
rocket stuff looked [ __ ] cool in
terms of the head it's the bit where you
know he was like he called him a you
know [ __ ] records I mean I'm not a
raccoon he's like fine you're a trash
Panda and he was like it looks at Jax's
like he's a good thing and drugs like I
don't know don't understand guys queues
doorman Bob I can't wait [ __ ]
currently inclusion of Kurt Russell
and they showed us a look at Sylvester
Stallone in the trailer which we didn't
know is in there so that means tango and
cash are in your [ __ ] garden she'll
see sequel man James Gunn doing the
Lord's [ __ ] work man for heaven's
sakes giving us a good time at the
movies
so Marvel once again kick major ass but
everyone expected that they skipped all
H last year yeah and they 23 of them
came back with a [ __ ]
fury this year and stuff like that but
between the two Marvel vs. DC who wins
Hall age this year I mean I feel like
the surprise was on DC side because we
didn't expect Wonder Woman to come so
hot we didn't expect justice at all and
Marvel is like a tent revival like you
go there knowing you're gonna feel the
power of God and you're incredibly happy
that
so it's like who won hard to say we all
won all of us won everyone we're
audience wins but who takes them I feel
like Marvel came really heavy you think
so
I think guardians the second bath or
guardians Thor Black Panther announcing
Captain Marvel spider-man yeah I think
Wonder Woman is still the single best
thing that I saw
I'm not agree with it but I feel like
Marvel as a whole sort of one I think
you may be right
like it turned like just by sheer volume
yeah DC has well I mean DC is about to
win a big bad way with Suicide Squad you
can make all the money yeah so then
after that they've got Wonder Woman and
after that they got Justice League and
that's pretty much all they show this
which was [ __ ] them yeah plenty cuz
we didn't think we'd get any of it yeah
yeah I would say ultimately by virtue of
the fact that like Marvel like did you
see that [ __ ] Marvel photo at the end
like were that everybody on the stage oh
my god I was backstage I could have
[ __ ] hit any one of them if they
rolled up tissue injury like that he's
crazy
the chadwick boseman would have been
unhappy yeah come on on the back of his
house he'll meet issues I just said a
rolled-up tissue we knew what you were
doing but that's what you want to do
yeah man I guess yeah I don't know like
I'm trying to think all right well I saw
guardians trailer in Hall H but I've
been able to watch it since because them
released it right here all right we
could do this use all those
qualifications whether like you know
[ __ ] this is the best opening and a
February the notion of let's see Marvel
released the Doctor Strange trailer
right DC released new squad new Justice
League new Wonder Woman so in terms of
released trailers to the public DC wins
hands down yes
in terms of in the room now I wasn't
there for DC but I can imagine when they
[ __ ] bring out all those justice
leaguers and announce Justice League
there was a religious fervor in that
room as well and folks felt just
instantly coming and stuff like that but
having been there for four guardians I
can't I don't know how many things beat
that that fervor in the room yeah like
it was it was unlike anything I'd ever
Burian Stan Hall age that is 11 or 12
movies worth of [ __ ] goodwill
including a [ __ ] down a good well for
the first guardians of the galaxy and
then you add in liberal dollop severes
your childhood with [ __ ] Kurt Russell
and [ __ ] that might have been the
amalgam that might have been the The
Alchemist [ __ ] meal of Hall Lakes
that was probably the most fans
satisfying
I haven't will I haven't been in
holidays for a Marvel panel since 2008
maybe 2007 the first Iron Man panel
really I was in room for that and that's
what it felt like seeing Wonder Woman
that's sort of like holy [ __ ] they did
it like that's he's flying Wow that was
the feeling to the Wonder Woman trailers
are calling [ __ ] they did it yeah I
don't even know what they were doing
they did it like this is fantastic they
got all my money all both these
companies got all our monies man take
them all oh let's do it off the back of
my hand that's all your take all that
[ __ ] gold off my skin I love this
[ __ ] for one reason one reason only the
only reason I stay alive hmm
life is not worth living except for
these movies I've got a wife and I've
got a kid [ __ ] these movies but what
get me out of bed in the morning so
please keep making them very excited how
lucky we are to be alive right now my
friend what a golden age of wonder you
know what I'm saying like we could have
been alive back in like [ __ ] old
times where you're like scavenging for
food and running from dinosaurs I guess
that would never happen because we never
lived with the dinosaurs but you know
what I'm saying I mean according to some
people who aren't scientists we all
totally live with darkness if you go
with religion absolutely but here we are
on this glorious age we're not getting
eaten by dinosaurs like nah
saber-toothed Tigers you like that
because we're watching movies and a
multiplex of our favorite character if I
have to choose between death on the
Savannah and theater watching a movie
like this I'm gonna die in a theater
watch this hopefully it's a good movie
hopefully I don't go out like they've
walked it up and then die if I have to
die the diabetes while sitting in a
movie theater I will do so why don't you
pick the diabetes of all things out of
the candy there you go
and with that kids don't eat too much
sugar that's the moral of today's
moderation episode and marvel a fat man
of that man thanks for hanging out we
got to talk about all the shows now
you're all caught up just like we're
caught up man come back next week or
next episode we're going to talk about
something completely different but until
then I bet Kevin Smith I've been mark
barnard and come back to see fat man on
Batman right here next time saying fat
time saying fat challenge sometimes it's
mana to cast calm or sometimes
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder